-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is so wonderful to hear
Let's get to the news.
Today is the 100th day
of Joe Biden's presidency.
Wow, that's crazy.
It's felt like exactly 100 days.
President Biden was greeted with
standing applause last night
when he entered
the House Chamber
to deliver his first
joint address to Congress.
Let's take a look.
[ All groaning ]
-Ooooouuuuuch!
-Way, way too many groans.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, when we used to
have an audience,
we would test material
earlier in the day.
And so, now, a lot of times,
I'm seeing things
for the first time, as you do.
And sometimes, we get it wrong
[ Laughing ]
During his first
address last night
to a joint session of Congress
President Biden called on
Democrats and Republicans
to come together to pass
police reform legislation,
though not everybody
stood up for that one.
President Biden
called on Congress last nigh
to create a new agency to
develop breakthrough treatment
for diseases such as Alzheimer's
and cancer -- and who knows?
Maybe even narcolepsy.
The 2021 NFL Draft began today
and the Jacksonville Jaguars
have the first pick.
Said a spokesman,
"Great, we pick Orlando."
In a new interview, a doctor and
clinical consultant for NASA
said that sex in space
would be difficult.
When asked why, the doctor said,
"Well, we've been married
a long time."
[ Laughter ]
According to new research,
gossiping about other people
can have positive effects.
Oh, you know
who should try it, then?
[ Whispers ] Ashley.
Microsoft announced yesterda
that it will retire
its default font, "Calibri,"
and replace it with one of these
five new typefaces --
Tenorite, Bierstadt, Skeena,
Seaford, and Grandview.
Either that, or Microsoft is
opening a day-care in Brooklyn
"Skeena!
Grandview, Tenorite!
Stop -- Stop teasing Grandview
He's a Bierstadt!
Of the Long Island Bierstadts.
A greep --
A group, excuse me.
I'm bummed that I messed u
the top of this joke.
[ Laughter ]
Don't hold it
against the writer
that I flubbed at the top.
'Cause every now and then,
there's one that's
so pristine...
Bays already said this was -
and I hope you don't mind me
putting words in your mouth --
the best joke he's ever written.
A group of elite
classical cellists in Denmar
recently performed
an outdoor concert
for a group of cows.
Said the cows, "They were good
but they're no Yo-Yo Moo."
[ Laughter ]
We have to legally tell yo
that if you've heard that joke
even if you're double-vaxxed
you can catch coronavirus.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] It makes no sense
"Yo-Yo Moo."
It only makes sense if the onl
noise Yo-Yo Ma made was "Ma.
[ Laughter ]
This is the other thing --
not to tell you
how things used to be
and how things are now.
Writers used to come in,
and we'd read
all the jokes together.
And so, as I read it, they would
have to look me in the face.
And now, they don't.
They just sit at home
and send in Yo-Yo Moo.
[ Laughter ]
According to new research, the
night shift mode on your phone
does not help you
sleep better at night,
because at the end of the day,
you know what you did.
And finally, a rare
bottle of bourbon
that is believed to have bee
produced before 1802
will go up for auction
later this year
and is expected to sell
for up to $40,000.
Meanwhile, an NFT
of a photo of it
is expected to sell
for $7 billion.
And that was
the monologue, everybody!